what's happened to reject nation Greg
Alba here is John Humphrey over here so
we're gonna watch today a trailer for I
love you daddy
oh boy it's a Louie CK starring in it
wrote it and directed it
he probably edited it too because that's
what he does and if you're expecting it
to be hilarious it's probably gonna be
very dark I guess the way Louie likes to
make his material yeah wants to come
live with you you have a giant apartment
and you have the Hamptons and the plane
none of that is my fault
you divorced me while I was a loser so
you lost can we get the check
[Music]
let me think about it later okay I don't
know daddy
well we'll talk about it okay okay lucky
I love you a girl that age is getting
into trouble and if she loves her daddy
that means you're doing nothing
girlfriend oh god no that's my daughter
China oh wow she's gorgeous that's
Leslie good one I've wanted to meet him
my whole life I'll be the best filmmaker
the last 30 years or more okay well he
also deeds freely young women and he's
what like 80 years old I am Leslie hi hi
during your feet actress and hiring a
pregnant movie star
sorry that's what's called for buying
[Music]
China she is a child she knows nothing
she's like a Disney Princess on estrogen
she could do a lot worse it's my
daughter China is a minor
[Music]
interesting time for this movie to get a
trailer right oh yeah
and given that louis c.k doesn't
necessarily have the cleanest sexual
history either no no no not at all and
also given the fact that he's kind of
getting his Woody Allen on yeah yeah it
really is
you know if we're just going in a
microcosmic way I think louis c.k is a
very talented writer director performer
etc so like on that merit alone I am
interested but yes so weird
yeah oh I'm surprised kinda that this
trailer is here yeah I was they didn't
push this or anything yeah yeah pastor
everything's going on cuz with the whole
all that stuff with John Malkovich and
Chloe grace Moretz
I mean Chloe grace Moretz is I think
she's 20 in real life with she's playing
a sixteen-year-old girl or something
right she's playing a minor no and with
all the stories coming out beyond Harvey
Weinstein but all the actresses who are
coming forward about their terrible
experiences when they were mine like
Jennifer Lawrence at her her whole
speech Reese Witherspoon talking about
it recently a lot of actresses are
talking about it maybe they thought well
this is relevant but to put it in like a
comedic tone very controversial
questionable taste for the current
moment and and all I can wonder is I
don't know is this movie gonna take that
character to task in any way how far
they gonna go cuz Louis CK's not one to
shy away from certain types of things so
I'm wondering like how far are they
gonna go oh yeah was that specific
storyline in that relationship well I
love you daddy and it seems it seems
like it's the central focus of this is
his relationship with his daughter and
what his daughter's doing well she's
also you know developing a love with a
woman with a guy who could be her father
yeah so I'm sure that title is meant to
play as a double entendre of sorts if I
take out all the real-life things that
have been going on lately in the public
I can respect a lot of what I was seeing
on here because it does have that Woody
Allen esque touch to it that I feel like
a lot of comedians like to honor
and so has that Woody Allen s touch and
I like that it's in black and white and
it just seems like overall the tone and
the style of how he's shooting it is
reminiscent a more classic old-school
Hollywood films the fact that it's
modern day with that type of cinematic
style I'm not sure whether or not why
they didn't push this like later because
maybe by making it old-school Hollywood
is even showing how times really haven't
changed all that much because you hear
horror stories of that type of sexual
assault and abuse that would occur a lot
in yeah in old-school Hollywood so maybe
maybe it's like kinda clever in showing
that hey times really haven't changed in
the way how things function all the
actors look great in it I like when
Chloe grace Moretz does more daring
roles like this and louis c.k looks like
he's doing a really good job and actors
like John Malkovich and Rose Byrne and
Helen Hunt are all fantastic and Charlie
Charlie David looks a little more
subdued he doesn't look as out there as
he usually yeah no probably have one
good three count
yeah you need he has to have that at
least one time I'm glad it doesn't just
look like a dark movie it's probably
gonna lay more in the darker comedy
spectrum as Louie CK likes to do with
his actual storytelling abilities yeah
Pamela Adlon who was the played his wife
in lucky Louie and she's a big
characters big character on Louie and so
you know there are frequent
collaborators already tends to hire her
this seems like it could be a solid film
in a lot of ways I'm questioning the
Biebs and like you said Louie CK has not
been as much in the public eye but I've
heard stuff you've heard you have
celebrity gossip stuff has reported
things about there easy yeah you know
yeah and there have been a few comedians
around lately who have been like hey
dude like respect but also you gotta set
this stuff straight ya know and and I I
do think that it is important to
acknowledge like problematic figures
because this is a hard debate it's like
you don't necessarily have to hate
everything that they do but you know I
do think that he should rectify some of
these things which is kids can be very
heartbreaking for me because Louie CK is
easily my favorite stand-up comedian
oh yeah and I mean he brings a lot of
nuance to the things that he works on
whether it's
or like I got really into Louie partly
because of the stylistic and the subject
matter the nuance with which he
approaches all those things and the
discomforts of life that he has to dive
into so on the one hand I'm like I'm not
surprised that you've got these scandals
that's probably part of why you have the
experience to talk the way they do but
yeah it does feel a little funny this
seems like a world that he obviously has
a good understanding of ya know
Hollywood and being a father being a
father such a big part of what a
stand-up is about I mean the show
focuses a lot of him being a father I
could see this being a good film it's
just comedy film to be coming out so the
world's mess can tolerate certain things
anymore yeah push this back to April for
all we know this could just be a
meaningful film for all we know for all
we know this could be something where
you're like this is a good
representation of what Hollywood is like
that's what I'm where it's nothing like
the trailer you know yeah I'm wondering
if maybe they sat down and went look
this is gonna be a part of the
conversation no matter what if we
release it now but maybe the movie has
you know a better message or something
there is also relevant and we just
haven't seen it play out yet knowing his
writing in terms of his storytelling
like he makes jokes understand it bits
about anything and everything like crazy
those jokes nothing is safe but in terms
of his storytelling he tends to keep it
more on the real side like I don't think
I'd walk away from this film being like
he was making fun of you know old
Hollywood producers taking advantage of
younger I don't think he would make like
I don't think it would make light of it
I don't think at the end of the day
you'd be like it's funny you know yes so
who cares
boys will be bullet yeah yeah exactly
interesting experience there subscribe
to the reel rejects click the
notification bell so you always get
notified one of our videos is out dad
shot Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram
I'm at the greg alba you could check out
our patreon become a patronage act today